hello I'm allegedly andrew heaton and
you're watching fake news mostly weekly
this week the internet is abuzz with
talk about Roy Moore in fact I believe
we have footage of some of the public's
reactions man to the indicated thises
are chosen and fitted Republican Roy
Moore is gunning for the US Senate seat
Alabama a seat still sticky from where
Jeff Sessions hit is hard candy so far
nine women have come forward to accuse
Moore of sexual misconduct several of
whom were minors at the time if he'd
been convicted Moore could have faced a
prison sentence of up to ten years which
may not be the first time
Moore's expose himself to something of
up to ten years yeah Roy Moore has so
far denied all the allegations though he
has suggested he would be happy to spend
some time in juvie really all right I'm
not here to tell you whether Moore is
guilty or not but I can tell you that
Roy Moore is guilty of molesting our
freedom
he's diddling our democracy and he's
inviting rule of law up to his hotel
room for a massage and a movie deal so
here are 13 non pedophile reasons why
you can hate Roy Moore he's a terrible
judge on two separate occasions the
Alabama Court of judiciary unanimously
defrocked Moore at last the defrock er
has become the de Franchi the court
deemed more grossly inconsistent with
his duties and incomplete misleading and
manipulative in their unanimous vote to
dfrac him unanimous courts are never
unanimous the Supreme Court wasn't even
unanimous about whether or not to
legalize but stuff Roy Moore is a
terrible judge because he doesn't
actually believe in upholding the law
unless he personally agrees with it
being a judge who refuses to uphold laws
is like being a birdwatcher who refuses
to watchbirds what is the point of view
Moore thinks the Bible supersedes the
Constitution and that God is the quote
only source of our law liberty and
government end quote so let's say that
we ghost the founding fathers burn the
Constitution and say screw it to a 200
year old consensus and we decide to
merge church and state well whose church
it's not like there's I don't know
8,000 different Protestant denominations
with their own interpretations of the
Bible and look I'm not anti religion I
love Christianity I love what you did
with Western civilization is terrific
but we have separation of church and
state for good reason the first time
Moore got defrocked it was for unveiling
a five-ton Ten Commandments monument
inside the state judicial building in
2005 he authored the Constitution
Restoration Act which would empower
Congress to remove any judges who failed
to uphold God's law you know who else
thinks that God is the only source of
law that cabdriver
Moore is so untied to reality were facts
that he believes Sharia law governs
parts of the country according to Moore
there are communities under surreal law
right now in our country open Illinois
they have Sharia law as I understand it
in Illinois Indiana up there when asked
how he knew that he said how was he
formed because that's what we wanted a
judge no concern for reality and I don't
know what more is complaining about when
his principles overlap with radical
Islam quite nicely Moore is a homophobe
war described homosexuality as a brought
a more detestable a crime against nature
you'd think for a guy with such a
penchant for leather vests he'd be more
open to the gays more not only defied
the Supreme Court's 2015 ruling on gay
marriage he instructed Alabama's probate
judges to do the same Roy Moore is
quoted as saying maybe Putin is right
with his opposition to gay marriage
quick note when you start a sentence
with maybe Putin is right you're wrong
unless the sentence ends with about to
drop a sick beat hit it
and around it out here's a quick list of
other reasons Roy Moore is a human HPV
virus he taught a class discouraging
women from running for office he's
referred to people as reds and yellows
he thinks the pedophilia accusations are
pushed by homosexuals and socialists
accepted money from a neo-nazi group
said gay marriage was worse than slavery
wouldn't rule out the death penalty for
gays wants to resent free trade
agreements anti-immigrant believes Obama
wasn't born in America believes 9/11 is
God's punishment for legalizing sodomy
and abortion so in summation Roy once
some candy Moore is pretty much the
closest thing we have to an American
Taliban and finally if all of those
reasons weren't enough to convince you
that Roy Moore is a petty tyrant and
therefore a bad person there's no way
he's not a pet
[Applause]
[Music]